everyone I'm Victor epic and I am a PhD
student and Seraphin but socko's lab
today I'm going to briefly talk about
our work on cancer phylogenetic
inference using multisample somatic
variants so as we know cancer is driven
by the accumulation of somatic mutations
and if we look inside it's jimmer will
find that it actually consists of a
mixture of cell populations each one
carrying a distinct signature of the
accumulated parents that come for some
kind of fitness advantage to the cells
in order to characterize this
heterogeneity better and allow us to
infer a more accurate cell lineage of
the cells inside tumor many recent
studies have now extracted actually
multiple samples from a particular tumor
beat at from different regions of the
tumor or from different points in time
in the tumor progression so one of the
projects that actually looked at
multiple biopsies of breast cancer data
at different progressions and in the
breast cancer evolution was the work of
our lab with in cooperation with the
School of Medicine Stanford in
particular professor a robbed West and
r0 and in this particular project they
were looking at reconstructing the
lineage trees and defining the virginity
of breast cancer samples however they
were doing that manually so we decided
to further this work and provide actual
computational technique that would allow
it to scale too much more samples many
more mutations and you know to handle
this this type of problem much faster
anyway so this is a project called
litchi again in collaboration with R&C
down Rob West and particularly with the
postdoc rahila cellar in our lab and the
goal of this project was to have a fast
computational method that would allow us
to infer cancer lineage trees and
decompose each cancer sample into its
sub homes while using multisample
variants such as somatic
isn't this okay so the input data to our
method is essentially a matrix where we
have each row corresponding to a
different single nucleotide variants on
V and each column is actually the very
low frequency of this variant in across
the different samples that we have
access to so again this could be
different regions of the same tumor for
instance and our goal is then to take
this data and to infer kind of a
hierarchy or ordering of these mutations
so place them on a lineage tree as well
as decompose the particular each sample
into the constituent subclones that
we've been for providing the proportions
of this club shopkins in the sample and
just a small note here is this method
can be generalized to work with other
variants however this assuming that will
have access to something that would
estimate the fraction of the variant in
the samples which is actually a very
hard problem so for things like and SVS
and other type of variants are more
complicated this is hard to estimate but
there's a lot of work on that generates
these magics so this general is so this
is directly following from the
sequencing data so we just compute the
number of reads that covered that have
the variant I suppose over the total
number of reads that we have a
particular company in particular
variation right so this gives adjust the
row frequencies right now yeah well
we're just like 0.1 yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah definitely so we have our
own heuristic Oh method that actually
will look at the different variants and
the frequencies and try to estimate
whether this actually is a true variant
or not I'll talk about this in the
second but this is actually a
challenging problem so we do work with
raw parent at your frequencies the way
they are but there are actually a lot of
dedicated methods that have specifically
been designed to call there and given
very low fractions of
reasons I've cover it so it's a teacher
challenger problem so we are looking at
deep sequencing data so that's why we
which allows us to have much more
reliable frequency information it's the
most of them is just targeted so it
right so the data sets that we analyzed
actually that I'll describe actually in
a second they they validate a particular
like let's say a few hundreds mutations
to the very high depth and I'll talk
about this but yeah that's a very good
point this is a big challenge so in our
method we make this kind of the big
assumption that we make is that our data
follows the perfect for large any model
also known as the infinite sets
assumption which basically states that
the mutations do not require
independently in different cells that
means that if self share particular
mutation they must have inherited from a
common ancestor this is a main
assumption so this assumption allows us
to formulate three constraints the
directly follow which you might have
seen in literature in particular let's
say we have two mutations than one and
m2 and a set of samples in which they
occur and let's say we do know that they
are actually there now if a mutation is
such as empty you actually occurs and
more samples at m1 it couldn't have been
a successor of m1 ok this would violate
the assumption that mutations don't
recur independently in this additional
sample as to hear so in another
constraint also directly following is
that a mutation but the lower frequency
value couldn't have really been a
predecessor of a mutation with the
higher frequency value and here assuming
that we're not looking at a cnv region
and again that we have reliable vas ok
and finally the third is if we're
looking at a group of mutations one of
the that's a mutation number one here
can only be a predecessor to a set of
disjoint mutation friends and
disciplines if there are low frequency
is lower than the frequency only if it's
lower than the frequency of the parent
okay so in this case m1 couldn't have
been apparent to both m2 and m3 because
the sum of these children mutation
supersedes exceeds the sum the frequency
of the parent and again this is directly
from following directly from the perfect
phylogeny model so given these
constraints we our goal is to find a
lineage tree so for the given set of
mutations are we looking for the
registry that satisfy this constraint
this is our the go over model and our
main formulation is the following so
let's say that each mutation or a group
of mutations that occur in the same set
of subset of samples with the same
frequency is a node in the graph so we
define all the nodes to represent
mutations of group of or groups of
mutations with the same valves and
presence pattern across samples and what
we do is we look at each mutation each
node in a pairwise fashion and we place
an edge in the network between two nodes
if it's possible that the node the
parent node can actually be a valid
predecessor of the child node so it
satisfies constraints one and two that
I've defined so the parent is present in
a superset of the samples of the child
and its frequency in each sample is
higher than the frequency of the child
mutation across the samples in which the
child is present so we look at all these
groups each one of mutations which one
will be a node and we place an edge if
there is a potential presence
relationship so we would wind up with
something we call evolutionary
constraint Network which is essentially
a dag and it includes just all the
possible presence relations but in
reality it actually allows us to stream
the search space for the true lineage
tree substantially and have our method
be very fast yes you like that right no
this is just I have what I have a real
example in a second this is just what
this it can be yeah actually the example
have is close to this it doesn't have to
be dense depending depending the data is
quick question
pure constraints come from set inclusion
exclusion and you might even get cycles
so we cannot get seconds so basically
the parent node has to be a superset
with the higher frequencies so the the
edge is kind of followed in the
direction of Tours lower frequency
always and fewer sub-samples in there
you can have a single cycle eating the
extreme case you can have a single cell
assuming that you have the equal so how
so yeah so that's why the main point
here is that we group each each node so
if we do have mutations that occur in
the same subset of samples with same
frequency we group them that's kind of
yes executive with that so we're
guaranteed and I will of course we don't
have that every single mutation that
Coker's actually has exactly the same
frequency and the data due to the noise
so i will talk about this in the second
so okay so it follows directly from the
construction that the true lineage tree
which we assume to satisfy all of the
constraints will be embedded in this
graph right so some of the edges will
actually correspond to the true lineage
three we're trying to infer now so how
do we find it well what we do is we find
all the spanning trees in this
constraint network that also satisfy the
third constraint the light will derive
from the first of a logic model which is
the third constraint is that now we
don't move just a pairwise it just pairs
of nodes but we actually enforce that
the sum of the children let's say here
the frequencies in each sample don't
exceed the parent so we generate all the
spanning trees that satisfy the third
constraint one of those trees assuming
that the perfect phylogeny code will be
our true lineage three so this is the
main formulation and now I'll go very
quickly to basically the steps the main
steps of the method so the first step is
well how to be group how do we construct
the notes how do we group us and these
by a presence pattern and frequency such
that we assume that actually frequent is
a group together they indeed have is the
same fraction of cells that contain them
in the sample and then the second step
will be to construct the network given
our groups of a sandy
finally final step is to find all the
lineage trees in this network that
satisfy the third constraint so very
quickly how to groupon cluster so as I
mentioned we have a very will have a
naive kind of heuristic approach to
determine whether a mutation is in the
sample or not or whether what we're
looking at is actually noise so our I'm
not going to go into detail because we
all have time but we basically have to
hurt threshold below which and above
which we assume that the absence and the
presence are robust arab ass Turkey and
then we formulate a min set cover
problem to determine what happens to the
mutations in the gray zone where robust
mutations basically are able to pull the
guys into the proof into their presence
profiles that they have I don't know if
that many McCain says I can discuss this
further but there as I mentioned also
there are a lot of existing tools that
are specifically dedicated for this
problem and we allow users to plug in
whatever results they want to the method
so in particular will allow for each
mutation in the matrix for the user to
provide an additional column that tells
us exactly is this mutation believed to
be present or absent in the sample so in
fact so I didn't mention this actually
so what we really want for each mutation
is a type of a binary profile where we
denote with the one that mutation is
there and with this year that mutation
is not there so here we have a German
variant which is highly has a high
frequency in every single sample so it
has this 1111 profile in this case we
have a variant that is present and
sample one two and three so it gets this
binary profile okay so so there this
comes to the first way in which we group
the mutations which is by the bind your
profile so we collect all the mutations
that have the same profile into a sink
what we call a single smv group so in
this case this mutation will fall into a
group of mutations that have presents
only sample one two and three so this
guy respectively corresponds to these
three entrance this is again an
frequency and so on so we end up with
with these four groups permutations we
are focusing on somatic
mutations on this ignore the vert the
germline and now given this group's the
other thing that we wanted is that the
mutations that occur that are present in
each node also have similar frequency we
believe them to be have to have the same
proportion of cells that are present in
so we have a clustering step based on
valves for each smv group that we found
so first breaking down by binder pad and
then cluster we use here the out of the
box eam clustering for gmm but again
this is another step that we provide the
hook in the method for people to use
their own cluster in favor clustering
results and we can operate with that so
essentially we have our nodes and now
the the next step is to construct the
dag that I was mentioning in particular
given our clusters each one of them will
be a node in our network and then we
will put edges amongst the nodes that
satisfy the constraints one and two the
damage in particular that there will be
an edge if the binary profile of the two
nodes of the child node is a subset of
the parent profile and the violent a new
frequency image sample is lower than the
vent Italian frequency of the pants
let's say here all of the constraints
hold however here they don't I believe
it's a variant the above constraint
violation even though the profile was
fine yes sir okay almost there so
finally given the network will search
for all spanning trees this is one tree
that we find from this network and we
have actually I'm also putting here the
breakdown of the samples of the tree
gives us in particular if we were to
follow each distinct path in the tree
continue only the notes present at the
with mutations from the sample we can
get each subclone to be represented by
just a distinct paths of the tree here
we have this path and then this path
okay for simple one okay it's a very
quickly results well we used very nice
data
provided by Jarl enjoyed all CCRC she
didn't data set in which they collected
multiple samples from eight different
patients for total of highly validated
587 smv so this is deep coverage in
their analysis they used a multi-step
pipeline with calling SMBs clustering
and then running traditional maximum
parsimony approach so very thorough with
analysis with the San Manuel work anyway
we're and each on the same data set so
these are lychee results and these are
the trees from the paper and challenger
so 45 of the patients are trees were
identical for the other two they're
extremely similar and for one case there
is an interesting result that Lita was
able to find it found actually one more
sample to be heterogeneous that
challenger at all did not report so here
is actually a true constraint network
which is very similar to the graphic
show they modeled it for one of the
patients v's 007 for which we got an
identical tree so this is the network
the spanning tree looks is embedded with
the darker edges this is it and so our
results actually flipped from theirs but
if you were to follow each branch you
find the same decomposition of the
samples and the same branching as
they're constructed tree and to
construct the three what is the
difference so basically they first they
call the variance so they have kind of a
multi-step long pipeline where first
they call the variance an example then
the cluster samples this gives them the
binary profile so if you can see here
for sample are three for instance they
obtain two clusters the dominant and the
Minor cluster just based on a low
frequency but now they supplied this to
create the binary profiles of each
effective leaf so some of the mutations
are in dominant won't be in the minor
and now using just the binary profiles
they run maximum parsimony so
traditional phylogeny based approach
so in the next example actually have one
reason why imposing buff constraints
that we do during phylogeny construction
makes a difference so here we found an
additional sample to victory genius and
that happened because actually the group
of mutations that were private to this
sample occurred with the point 17
frequency however in their tree the
parent of this group of mutations
actually was a group of mutations shared
between our two nr4 but their frequency
was just so low at 0.06 so we actually
place this private group of presentation
or four is it descendant of a higher
note because the path constraint was
violated actually here so this is one
example very quickly we also have
results in the paper when go into it
from the baasha shot at all study that
looked at ovarian cancer and also had
collected multiple samples here is there
briefly results and this is um i don't
know if i have time for this okay so
I'll while this is running we have a GUI
to interact with our our method it it
was the getting Oscar buzz I would like
to acknowledge everyone on the project
in particular serve him in the pot so
cool lab also a lot of our collaborators
in the School of Medicine this is very
90s looking with updated essence them in
school of medicine particular Rob Westar
and sedo so okay and all the cooperates
on this project that listening
some questions so maybe take the
questions offline because I have a
gazillion questions starting with the
basic one that I don't see the
difference between the Sun set up but I
think you guys are going to do that so
we take the speaker again you should